>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK TO OUR
DEMOCRATIC DEBATE SPECIAL.
ELIZABETH WARREN WAS A PROFESSOR
AT HARVARD LAW SCHOOL.
VERY IMPRESSIVE.
SHE IS A RESEARCHER.
SHE'S GOT AN ACADEMIC MIND.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING SHE'S BEEN
ABLE TO DISCOVER COUNTLESS NEW
FORMS OF RACISM PERMEATING
AMERICAN LIFE.
TERMS OF NEVER HEARD OF BEFORE.
SHE LISTED THEM DURING THE
DEBATE.
>> WE NEED TO CALL OUT WHITE
SUPREMACY FOR WHAT IT IS.
DOMESTIC TERRORISM.
WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY NOW WHERE
THE PRESIDENT IS ADVANCING
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM, ECONOMIC
RACISM, CRIMINAL JUSTICE RACISM,
HEALTH CARE RACISM.
>> Tucker: WELL, SHE'S A LOT
OF FUN.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT IS SHE
TALKING ABOUT CUSTOMER WHAT IS
HEALTH CARE RACISM FOR EXAMPLE.
WHAT IS ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM.
I'M TRYING TO BE OPEN-MINDED,
BUT WE ARE GOING TO NEED SOME
HELP FIGURING OUT WHAT THOSE AR
ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
>> GOOD TO BE HERE AGAIN.
SO, YOU'VE BEEN IN AND AROUND
POLITICS IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
WORLD FOR MORE THAN 50 YEARS.
WHAT IS HEALTH CARE RACISM?
YOU HAVE ANY IDEA CUSTOMER >> AS
A VETERAN OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT, I FIND HER
INSULTING, CONDESCENDING, AND
PATRONIZING.
SHE ACTS AS A BARRIER FOR THE
INSPIRATION OF REAL SOLUTIONS
FOR FACES FROM BALTIMORE AND LOW
INCOME BLACKS.
THIS IS REALLY HARMFUL TO ANY
KIND OF DISCUSSION.
AS A VETERAN OF THE MOVEMENT, I
REMEMBER BACK IN THE 60s, I
LEFT THAT MOVEMENT, BECAUSE MANY
OF THE BLACKS WERE SACRIFICED
AND SUFFERED MOST DID NOT
BENEFIT FROM THE CHANGE.
DR. KING SAID, WHAT GOOD DOES IT
DO TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO EAT IN A
RESTAURANT WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
THE MEANS TO EXERCISE IT.
THE SWITCH CAME WHEN THE MONEY
ARRIVED.
THAT'S WHY THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
IN BLACK AMERICA TODAY ISN'T
BETWEEN WHITES AND BLACKS.
IT'S INTERNAL.
AND ELIZABETH WARREN AND PEOPLE
WHO CONTINUE TO EMPHASIZE THE
EXTERNAL ENERGY ARE PREACHING A
FALSE SOLUTION.
BLACK AMERICANS DESTINY HAS
NEVER BEEN DETERMINED BY WHAT
WHITE PEOPLE DO OR DO NOT DO.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE LEFT WITH.
AND SO, I THINK THAT IT DEFLECTS
ATTENTION AWAY FROM THE REAL
PROBLEMS.
AND THAT IS, THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE SERVING THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
RACISM IS NOT THE MOST IN
FORMIDABLE PROBLEM.
THE REAL PROBLEM IS THE KIND OF
BETRAYAL BY THE LEADERS OF THESE
CITIES IN THE LAST 50 YEARS.
THE URBAN COMMUNITIES, WHERE YOU
HAVE THE HIGHEST CRIME, THE MOST
DRUG-INFESTED, HAVE BEEN RUN BY
LIBERAL BLACK DEMOCRATS FOR 50
YEARS.
WE'VE SPENT $22 TRILLION IN
THESE PLACES, AND YET, THE
PROBLEMS ARE GETTING WORSE.
IN 1914, THEY CRAMMED OVER 4,000
BLACKS IN.
IN THE LAST 20 YEARS, BLACKS
HAVE BEEN DRIVEN OUT BY
GENTRIFICATION.
YOU DON'T SEE THESE LEADERS
ADDRESSING ECONOMIC ISSUES LIKE
THAT, BECAUSE THEY CAN AVOID
CONFRONTING THOSE ISSUES,
BECAUSE THEY USE RACE AS A
SHIELD.
WHITE PEOPLE COULD ALL GO TO
EUROPE TOMORROW, AND THE
CONDITIONS OF THE INNER CITY
WOULD NOT CHANGE.
AND NOT ALL BLACKS ARE SUFFERING
EQUALLY.
THERE ARE THREE ZIP CODES WHERE
THE MEDIUM INCOME IS A HUNDRED
$70,000.
THEY ARE THREE TIMES RICHER THAN
MOST WHITES.
IF RACISM WAS A PERVASIVE
PROBLEM, THEN WHY ARE NOT ALL
BLACKS SUFFERING EQUALLY?
I THINK IT'S TIME TO STOP THIS
PREOCCUPATION WITH RACE AND
RECALIBRATE AND COME TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS OF LOW
INCOME PEOPLE OF ALL RACES.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE A
COURAGEOUS MAN FOR SAYING THAT.
YOU ARE A COURAGEOUS MAN FOR
SAYING THAT.
MOST PEOPLE CAN'T SAY WHAT YOU
SAID AND CERTAINLY CAN'T SAY IT
AS CLEARLY AND INSIGHTFULLY AS
YOU JUST DID.
THANK YOU.
>> THEY ARE TRAITORS.
THEY REALLY ARE.
THEY NEED TO BE CALLED OUT FOR
IT.
GOLDSMITH, RIORDAN.
SO, ANSWERS EXIST.
WE JUST NEED TO PURSUE THEM.
BUT WE CAN'T DO IT AS LONG AS WE
STAY STUCK ON THE RACE GRIEVANCE
ISSUE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
IT JUST DIVIDES PEOPLE.
BUT ELIZABETH WARREN BENEFITS